who here works all the hours of the day
okay half of you if your business is not
growing as fast as you want it to you
are working on the wrong stuff if it has
stayed the same and you were spending
all your time working on it it means
that you have not properly identified
the constraint of the business you're
not going to get more hours so you're
doing the wrong if you do not know
what the contraint of your business is
you will not solve it you'll continue to
do the you have been doing and that
has not been getting you what you want
so right now unless you change the
activities you do you will not change
the getting that you are getting